die afd ist im bundestag ein schwarzer
tag für deutschland einer von uns muss
zu afd
der andere zur cdu hallo
wie wäre das ergebnis wohl geworden wenn
merkel wahlkampf geführt hätte
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen besser
aber mit diesem ergebnis was wir haben
können wir sicherlich nicht zufrieden
sein
also stimmen sie mir zu dass sie keinen
wahlkampf geführt hat sie hat ein
wahlkampf geführt aber ich glaube die
umfragen waren deutlich besser
in welchem land haben in deutschland
tatsächlich die waren vor vier bis fünf
wochen tatsächlich ein bisschen besser
als die jetzt welche partei die cdu
tatsächlich das habt ihr das mitbekommen
zufrieden mit dem ergebnis
was hoffen sie für die zukunft mehr
demokratie und freie meinungsfreiheit es
ist tatsächlich im augenblick noch eine
männerpartei ist also es gibt halt ganz
viele frauen die einen doktortitel haben
und dann gibt es ganz viele männer die
sind die absolut größten holzköpfe die
ich je gesehen genau und männer selbst
es ist gerade so fast wie ein sinnbild
der afd dass ich hier eine sehr
intellektuelle frau mit kulturmagazin
habe und einen mann aus zwickau der an
allen brot wie erklären sie sich diese
differenz zwischen männern und frauen im
prototyp
da kommen schnell sein bei dir gespart
haben grenze zu machen und
volksabstimmungen durch die zwei punkte
dann sind wir schon zufrieden ausbauen
aber sie sind ja jetzt auch eigentlich
in mitleidenschaft gezogen worden von
einer geschlossenen grenze sie wollten
gerne da rein was essen und dann haben
sie nicht eingeladen innere grenze ja
dass erinnerungen könnte setzen sie all
ihre hoffnungen auf merkels nächsten
türkei-besuch ich glaube das wird so
schnell nicht hin aber dann würde sich
vielleicht verhaftet werden und sie
werden das problemlos aber es ist ein
problem offensichtlich haben sie jetzt
geschickt mir die worte im munde
verdreht
ich bin nicht mitglied der öfter ich bin
also ich treffe mich eigentlich hiermit
mein freund aber es hat mir gedacht ich
gucke mir das ganze mal an ich war
gerade da vorne nicht mehr biete also
sie treffen sich am wahlsonntag vor der
afg party location in einem afd blauen
hemd mit einem freund ja es ist das ist
eigentlich zufall das blaue hemd
party im endeffekt und ich habe leider
kein anderes blaues hemd zu hause
deswegen habe ich jetzt das ist also sie
sind gegen eine koalition mit der afg
die könnten sie doch auch kaputt
koalieren wie sie das mit der fdp oder
spd gemacht haben
nein das geht ja nicht so dauert ja
wieder das dauert ja wieder was da
zusammenkommt zeiten des
rechtspopulismus sind auch zeiten für
die linke satire was ist ihr
persönlicher humor
mein persönlicher amorin mit blick auf
linkspopulisten oder was auch immer sie
unter humor verstehen
ich sage jetzt einen witz machen wenn
sie möchten sehr gerne
also ich mach mal ein witz die kanzlerin
ist immer noch nicht zurückgetreten das
ist doch eigentlich ganz schön witzig
oder ja ich würde sagen
hier haben sie das publikum für diesen
witz gefunden viel erfolg beim opener
ist in gefahr
dann hätte ich einen setup kommt die
kanzlerin zum arzt
helfen sie mir geht's weiter sagt der
arzt
hier ist aber dreckig ich glaube ich
brauche eine putzfrau die schwarz
arbeitet
was kann ich denn konkret machen und sie
die öffentlich-rechtlichen besser zu
gestalten so ein interview wie heute mit
ihnen ja also sie waren einfach im
fernsehen kommen und dann ist koran ich
bin ins fernsehen kommen aber so ein
faires interview wo nicht die haken
fragen gestellt werden wo hinter der ein
großer große publikation gemacht wird
also nicht dass ich sie jetzt in sachen
frage wie ist es nicht wirklich so dass
nicht nur nazis die fdp wählen sondern
auch einfach idioten genau das würde die
frage gar nicht gefallen würde die sind
leider zu oft gefallen
[Musik]
hessel ja nimmst du mich mit in die
schweiz
nein wir nehmen keine ausländer nazi
[Applaus]